this is Action Bronson oh [ __ ] I have a
[ __ ] hole in my pocket oh and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me that was a good one
come on ours [ __ ] I'm Wally let's do
this let's do this all right so we're
gonna start off with twitter at stanky
pac whoa whoa why'd Action Bronson cut
the beard I'm hot don't [ __ ] talk to
me I cut the beard because 6 a.m. I was
stoned stoned beyond belief and you know
when you go and you try and give
yourself a little bit of trim a little
shape up it usually doesn't work out
well and that's what happened I made one
wrong move I used the number 3 what was
I doing using number 3 on a [ __ ]
beard like that of course it was gonna
take a big chunk out of it so then I had
to just take it all off I hadn't seen my
face with 12 years I forgot what I look
like but I am a hunk and I'm hot there's
no doubt about whether I have face on my
hair and not the structure of this face
the Balkan features that's why I don't
even wear sunglasses in this segment I
needed to show these [ __ ] off
why does Action Bronson always eat
standing up it makes me nervous to be
honest I feel like when I eat standing
up it just falls straight down it
doesn't get stuck around this area you
know I feel like it's better for the
metabolism it keeps me moving also it's
like I'm working out and eating at the
same time I have an issue with nervous
legs where I do this a lot and I can't
stop from swaying it runs in my family
what's next who's my current favorite
wrestler I like Finn Balor that's my guy
but I like the Japanese wrestling I
liked old sure I liked psychosis I liked
Sabu I like who else know I like I like
Rey Mysterio when he was still
mysterious zesty Celestia Celestia
fiesta
you know what did Action Bronson look
like in high school
you're looking at it Punk
Fox you know pull the picture up of me
in high school it's [ __ ] embarrassing
but it's gorgeous honestly people would
die for the hair that I had literally on
the floor and just died done I will move
on to Instagram now oh look at that
that's a picture of my dome the back of
my dome celestial cathedrals done by Dan
Santoro one of the greatest tattoo
tattoo artists of this century that's
beauty right there
I'm piece of art I'm a walking art
exhibit this is an installation that
we're doing right now anyway in essence
yeah oh wait I didn't even answer the
[ __ ] I didn't realize there was a
question on Instagram is it a cathedral
yes ready here we are
Action Bronson leaves his label
announced his white Bronco mixtape white
Bronco is coming it's a [ __ ] journey
oh it's unbelievable
wasn't assigned to Vice wonder if this
affects my TV shows no because we carved
the TV shows out of any other deals we
did catch me everywhere
vice related for now what's next
Cora Cora croire
what is this cold is Action Bronson an
old school or new rapper I'd say that
I'm a renaissance rapper and I'm also a
medieval futuristic rapper I would say
that there's really no label label put
on me whatsoever
I draw influences from like 20 lifetimes
ago this already happened I'm [ __ ]
bored already what's next what does it
like to know me know me in a biblical
sense or to know me to know me is to
actually understand me and for that to
happen you have to feel what I feel
inside of my feelings
how much does Action Bronson way right
now 3:15 and I wear it well it's a lot
it's in the midsection have a broad
shoulder base [ __ ] pretty jacked
considering I haven't done anything in
years my legs that's where all the you
know the legs are where the power is
squat thousands of pounds leg press like
you can't believe one would compare me
some if you were gonna compare me to
anybody in life matías to Janowski who's
next
YouTube this is a beautiful picture of
me and my friend Clovis in front of the
yard restaurant people in Paris don't
even mind if you light up at a cafe I
don't care whether they mind or not to
tell you the truth I don't mind I'm not
here for anybody else's acceptance I
have to do what's right for me I have to
get my [ __ ] right my rock my rock hash
to back that back zero zero
thats what they would screamed to me in
the street when I smoked weed they
usually tell you what they're smoking
they say hashish and then they give you
their favorite football player guru
Olivier zero you know tap back to back
he's smoking a [ __ ] cigarette hashish
hashish would hash in it what's next
Wikipedia Bronson was born in Flushing
Queens
I arrived like terminator naked kneeled
kneeling in front of a [ __ ] fence on
fire that's how I arrived into this
world and then I went into a biker bar
and I've stole my first outfit Action
Bronson sites fellow American rappers
Kool G Rap knives Cam'ron mobb deep UGK
and the wu-tang clan is major influences
I feel like all of those are spot-on but
I would also add to the music that
really influenced me early on like some
of the like Michael Jackson like Carlos
Santana
was one of the first albums I love like
Queen to Albanian singers wedding
singers from Albania that come and play
[ __ ] electric clarinet in your ear
crazy dude dude nuts [ __ ]
dancing with the that's a that's a
handkerchief that I'm spinning Yahoo
Answers yeah who did Action Bronson
deserved you of the year probably not
I'm a [ __ ] human being a man I'm
gonna outer being a space cadet who
knows what this means what's a Jew well
thank you guys for asking me these
questions it's been an eye-opening event
turn the thing back so I can see that
it's actually me on the [ __ ] camera
flip it over it's a hunk I've ever seen
one and I've only seen one it's me thank
you